the leader of the digital decade welcome
thank you thank you so much cecilia
feldell
dear friends of digital europe ladies
and gentlemen
thank you very much for this opportunity
well
indeed at the very beginning of my
mandate i
put digital innovation at the core of my
agenda
and the reason is simple the reason is
you the thousands of european digital
entrepreneurs
innovators and pioneers you
are the reason why i believe the 2020s
can be
europe's digital decade a decade
when europe becomes a global leader in
the digital world
because you have already planted the
seeds
for europe's digital decade and
let me start with just one example
this year the whole world has set its
eyes upon a small
european deep tech company biontech
biontech developed the first widely
authorized vaccine against covet 19
and the story of biontech is
amazing and ordinary at the same time
mayan tech is one of the many startups
born as a spin-out of a european
university
it all started with a handful of people
and a bold visionary idea it then grew
thanks to public funding
it is now attracting global investment
and it is delivering a safe and
effective vaccine
to the whole world
this is but one of europe's many success
stories
and the list of your nominees for the
future unicorn award
is equally impressive you have
from green energy to innovative
therapies
i mean many many other examples you are
showcasing the
immense potential of our digital sector
europe is now attracting more capital
for startups
at sea stage than any other region in
the world
europe's deep tech companies are worth a
combined 700 billion euros today
and they are growing at incredible speed
europe
is a rising digital power
i know that some of you in the audience
represent
big global companies who are investing
here in europe
precisely for this reason new ideas are
coming from the old continent
and this isn't only about startups in
deep tech
european industry as a whole
is entering a new era one
fourth of industrial robots in the world
are produced in europe
over 40 percent of europe's enterprises
have already adopted technology based on
artificial intelligence
so europe is going digital right now
as we speak
yet i'm convinced that europe is still
punching well below its weight
i believe this is because of two main
reasons
the first one obvious a lack of
investment
european companies invest massively in r
d in certain sectors
such as automotive or pharma
but our investment in other fields still
lags behind the us and china
and artificial intelligence and quantum
computing are two
good examples and think again
about the biontech case
technologies that will become decisive
in 10 or 15 years
are being developed right now by a
handful of people
in a lab or factory and we must make
sure that they find the resources they
need today
to become the next big thing of tomorrow
and the second issue we must tackle
concerns
rules and regulations
for years our digital businesses have
dealt
with way more obstacles than their
competitors abroad
and small and promising european
companies
have had a hard time when trying to
scale up beyond national borders
investment has been delayed because the
rules of the game were not
and as a result of all this
too many european businesses have left
our continent
in order to grow
today i would like to tell you about how
we are changing this
with more public investment and with
business friendly rules so that europe's
digital decade can begin
now first on investment of course these
are tough times for businesses all
across europe it is hard to plan
investment in the middle of a pandemic
with little certainty about the future
and this is one of the reasons
why we have put together next generation
eu
you know it the recovery plan worth 750
billion euros
which comes on top of the european
and the national budgets
next generation eu is the largest
digital investment plan europe has ever
seen
at least 20 percent of next generation
eu
will fund digital investment
and that means roughly 150
billion euros so next generation you
will
help bring high-speed internet to all
corners of our union including
our countryside it will invest in the
skills
european workers need for the digital
transition
on the experience of gaia x next
generation eu will support
the creation of a european cloud a
world-class infrastructure to store
and manage data with the highest
standards on security
on privacy and on data portability
and next generation eu will also support
the creation
and the expansion of digital
innovation hubs these are places where
businesses can find the digital
solutions they need
and thanks to digital innovation hubs
traditional industries
will learn that they will gain from
using data and artificial intelligence
and digital businesses will find new
investors
who can help them scale up so next
generation you can be a game changer
the fourth industrial revolution blurs
the lines between the digital and the
physical world you
are the vanguard of industry 4.0
and now next generation eu can help this
fourth industrial revolution
just to go mainstream
don't get me wrong i know that public
investment cannot change the world alone
so the second thought is that this is a
moment to join forces
to join forces between public and
private investors
last year for instance we created a new
european investment fund for artificial
intelligence and blockchain we are now
working together with the european
investment bank
with national investment banks and with
venture capital investors
in the first year we've put together 700
million euros of investment
and i'm sure we can reach 3 billion
euros this year
so for small digital business or deep
tech startup
this can make a world of difference
as resources from next generation eu
start to flow
into our economies it's now time
to join forces between the public and
the private sector
and there is a second field where the
european union can make a great
difference in our internal market
this year we are rewriting
the rulebook for our digital internal
market
i want companies to know that across the
european union
there will be one set of core digital
rules
instead of this patchwork of national
legislation and national regulators for
the same company
you know all digital business in europe
from riga
to bilbao should have the same
geographical horizon
the european single market with half a
billion consumers
and continent-wide opportunities
so we are creating a single set of rules
for all digital businesses operating in
europe
and this is why we have just presented
two new pieces of legislation
the digital services act and the digital
markets act
the digital services act defines the
responsibilities
of all digital actors operating in
europe
and the digital markets act will ensure
that the online world remains a space of
innovation and accessible to all players
big and small these are just the first
steps and more
are following now let me focus in
particular
on data and artificial intelligence
two sectors where the lack of clear
rules
creates uncertainty for businesses and
for customers alike
machine generated data can be the fuel
for europe's recovery we are literally
sitting on a gold mine every day
every european business produces data
without even
noticing research tells us that the
potential value of data produced in
europe
will soon reach 1.5 trillion
euros a year imagine 1.5
trillion and we are only using a tiny
percentage
of this treasure data can make our
fields more fertile
it can predict the machine's failure and
fix it before it even happens
data can cut europe's energy consumption
massively
with benefits for the planet and for
your balance sheets too
for all these reasons and many many more
data need to be shared and exchanged
more widely
and therefore companies need clear rules
on how to access share
and sell available data
last november we introduced a regulation
on european data governance
and later this year we will present
a data act and proposals on health data
spaces
what we want to do is to put
those who generate data in the driving
seat
if your business wants to buy or sell
data
you should be able to fully trust the
provider
of a data sharing service
you should know what they can do and
cannot
do with your data
of course there are certain conditions
under which data gathered by the public
sector
should be made available more widely
but all these examples show that it is
only with
clear rules that the data market can
finally take off
data are also the essential fuel of
artificial intelligence
and i want to be very clear on this
i believe in the power of artificial
intelligence
just look at the winner of last year's
future unicorn award
corti from denmark they are using ai and
voice recognition to help doctors
predict
heart attacks it's simply amazing
and indeed the possibilities of a.i are
immense i don't have to tell you
ai can turn on wind turbines and
can produce more energy as the weather
changes for example
ai can detect a cyber attack faster than
any human being
and as a medical doctor i know that ai
can also for example
detect cancer in mammographies
way earlier and more reliably
than any human being so ai
brings undoubtedly huge opportunities
but we also see the risks
linked to certain applications of ai
for example facial recognition in public
places
or decisions touching important personal
interest such as recruitment
so after months and months of public
consultation
this spring we will present a legal
framework
for artificial intelligence in europe
we will set some requirements
for high risk applications of ai
from making sure that they use high
quality
data to ensuring
human oversight
and in parallel we will present a new
plan to push
european excellence on ai
this is something that businesses like
yours
are asking more and more from policy
makers investment
but also clear rules for ai
you are telling us you don't want your
technologies
to be used for the wrong purposes
and when clear boundaries are set
innovation is
free to run its course
the innovations you are bringing to our
markets can
change the lives of millions and
in some cases they literally save lives
in the years ahead the power of data
and other digital solutions can help
countless businesses emerge from the
crisis
europe's digital sector can drive our
recovery
and we are determined to build the best
possible conditions
for this to happen with infrastructure
with skills with data clouds and funds
for ai
removing obstacles for rising unicorns
and giving certainty to investors
and this is how europe's digital decade
can begin
a decade when we become masters
of our digital future finally
masters of digital thank you very much
for your attention
you